[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are we ready to go
yeah is is sandler there is uh
is is uh christopher mcdonald there are
we are you guys ready
yes i am oh hi chris how you doing i'm
good
hi so a full intro if you're watching on
peacock that's a
christopher mcdonald he is a shooter
mcgavin on the right and that's adam
sandler
he's happy gilmore on the left uh let me
start with uh
the important person chris how were you
approached
for the role of shooter mcgavin uh
dennis dugan dennis duggan the director
found me in the in the uh we're up in
vancouver i was working on another movie
with ray liotta called unforgettable
and i ran into dennis dugan in the lobby
of the hotel he goes mcdonald we
want you for the script uh please take a
look at this part
it's awesome and that's how i that's how
it first
came across and then i of course like an
idiot wanted to turn it down because i
wanted to go see my family
so i thought you know a little toddlers
at home what dennis did
he went to robert simons the producer
and he said hey mcdonald will come if
you can get him to get his family up
yeah yeah is that it stanley but before
i had to do that i had to sit down with
adam
and i had to sit down to laugh for about
25 minutes so
oh yeah man i remember that chris when
we went out to eat me and you
exactly yeah i i i'll tell can i just
say two things chris
i do think uh dennis dugan
of course loved you and wanted you but i
saw
thelma and louise and everybody was
talking about this gorgeous guy in
thelma and louise and i went and saw it
and i
kept going he is gorgeous at this
red pit brad pitt i kept going i don't
see what they see in this guy but the
chris mcdonald guy
yeah but but sandman what did you want
shooter mcgavin to be
i wanted him to be strong an athlete
a guy that's very confident and would uh
not like uh old happy gilmore very much
and i played by the rules and kind of
grew up with golf
and then i remember chris when we went
to uh
lunch first of all chris didn't like the
fact that happy gilmore
was a little bit of a violent guy
because in real life chris
could knock me out right so she was like
i'm gonna let this guy
intimidate me he got very uh he didn't
love the fact that
old adam sandler was uh tough in the
movie but um
but i remember uh also talking handicaps
in the beginning right like you you were
you were playing a lot of golf then
i was yes i just happened to win a
tournament down with det left shrimp
down in
in seattle so i thought god i hope that
movie's still around and
sure enough i called dennis up and then
we got together when did you know
it was something unique chris
well you never know i don't think it was
just fun
it was a fun set it was really fun
material it
was uh great cameos by wonderful actors
i mean
come on joe flaherty jackass i mean
people like that just make me really
laugh and so
i i knew it was gonna be funny but i had
no idea it was gonna be
what it is today and that's uh i got
that is the
the beautiful thing right now because
it's generational it's
multi-generational
people are watching it with their
grandchildren so it's uh
it's got legs as they say sandman uh
tell me if this is true
uh did kevin costner shoot uh turn down
the role of shooter mcgavin
no no no no i never heard of that one no
i think the only guy we offered it to
was was uh chris
that's the right that's the right answer
of course yeah yeah yeah of course
i never heard of that one okay and bob
barker wasn't your first
choice for you to get into a fight with
tim hurley he wrote it for ed mcmahon
and then and then i think uh do you know
if it ever got to ed mcmahon
sandman i i really i doubt that but uh
so i think back then we we
would write something and expect them
personally didn't go
really we get to hang out with these
guys
i'm not doing that i got a life to live
you know but uh
i i doubt he got it i think we heard
something like uh
it's too vulgar or something for it or
something like that but it was a little
little i think the script was a little
rougher
uh we cursed a little bit more um and
then uh
when when ed said no we i think we
dialed it down a little bit for bob
barker and said
uh he's a daytime guy man let's let's go
but bob barker was just he was so cool
man
and he wanted to do all of his own
stunts yes yes he was fighting with
chuck norris
[Laughter]
and chuck was some stuff so uh
yeah bob was came ready to go it was
like really early in the morning when i
when we were on the set in vancouver we
up in a i think
big bear i'm not big bear i forget i
forgot the name of it bear
something something bear and uh it was a
beautiful golf course and
it was really cold but bob like at 6 30
in the morning was stretching out and
getting ready
chris your favorite day on the set
shooting
involved what oh i got a few of them but
i gotta say i'm a big fan of the uh
of the bar scene the 19th hole if you
will when uh
i'm sitting there but i love that buddy
i love that i love that scene it's just
so funny if you stand in my way you'll
pay
listen to what i can say the way that
ended was uh people
love love love that scene it was so much
fun to play because it was like
finally amano amano i got this guy who's
got this sick shot
and i just try to get him you know you
should go on those uh one of those uh
you know long drive contest should
probably do very well just get the hell
out of my life
so that kind of thing that was a really
funny scene and uh uh enjoyed doing it
and of course uh
in in uh in happy's happy place
you know julie bowen a couple of kegs a
couple of pitchers of beer and you know
and then that that was so awesome and
then of course grandma sucking on her
tongue
that was out there but fun
sandman did you cut out 30 minutes of
the film so you could get that pg-13
rating
i don't know i think the only thing we
had a hard time with that we probably
cut out stuff that didn't didn't work
but i do remember in the beginning you
know when happy gilmore curses a lot and
we keep beeping
beeping him and he's screaming at
missing a putt or something
uh i remember they would say you have to
make the beat longer
we're hearing too much of the curse so
we we would have to go back a lot and
make sure they
you only heard just a slight f or a
slight
c for somewhere or that kind of stuff
and and that was the only thing we had
to fight about
and who came up with the your approach
to your golf shot
uh that was me because i i i've told
this before but
what this the story was we were in
manchester new hampshire
and uh my father was a great golfer he
was very very just an
ex excellent golfer golfed all the time
he retired at 54 and just became a
real uh heavy-duty golf firm he'd go to
the range and i would go with them
and i brought my friend kyle mcdonough
who played pro hockey
um and kyle
at the time we were in high school was
never
really golf but was driving the ball so
far my father kept going man these
hockey kids
what a swing and he my father loved kyle
so much it was like
kyle was the only guy in my life that
i'd be like dad
remember i'm your kid man why
he loved kyle you loved god you loved
cop but
but uh my father would he was just a
sweetheart of a guy
a great athlete and a great kid and then
um so i remember this a few years later
we were talking about happy gilmore and
oh no we were talking about
our next movement i said my friend was a
hockey player who could
maybe be funny to make a movie about
that a hockey mentality
but gets invited on the golf tour and
then uh i wanted to do kind of a slap
shot
type of swing chris um you play the
villain well
did you want to play the villain
did i want to play the villain yeah uh i
have had a lot of success in
in plays before that i played iago and
uh you know othello
and i just love that that that richness
there they had a play with mark medoff
called when you're coming back red rider
where i was the you could hear a pin
drop that's how much
how that's how mean and and threatening
this guy was
so i learned to enjoy it and uh i just
think villains are a lot of fun
because you know we all have that in us
but uh
it's just delicious to be able to like
let it you know
go out carte blanche like that and uh so
i didn't mind that at all i just i
think it's the kinetic part that's the
hard part because
you're bouncing off a guy who's really
really funny but also very angry kind of
thing
so you're just kind of like oh you want
to play like that let's do this and so
it's like one upsmanship
and that's what thing works really well
in this movie uh
happy gilmore two sandman has that been
discussed
it has not been discussed but it
certainly has been discussed on the
internet
and uh and uh that that believe me that
senior tour idea i would
not it would be so amazing to go around
are you both in
sandman can i green light this
yes yes you can green light this i don't
know
this just into the dan patrick show
happy gilmore 2
has been green lighted or lit or
something like that
chris are you in i am double in yes
i would love to do it everybody's been
screaming for like adam said
on the internet and um you know i just
don't i
i i just got to say it would be a
complete blast the senior tour with us
too
oh my god what do people say to you on
the street chris
about this movie they say they love it
i mean it depends on where i am if i'm
in a ball game or you know any kind of
athletic event it's
shoot up they will they won't let me go
anywhere
the worst case scenario was i i was in a
in a restroom trying to relieve myself
at a ball game up in buffalo and got one
guy recognized me my hat was down i was
good
i got through the line got to the urinal
and he was like
dude you shoulda and it was crazy
i just thought it get me out of here now
but uh
but that happens in airports now dude
but if you walk in new york city it's
all kinds of different things they say
but
they wait for you to walk by and then
they go shoot her and i just kind of go
yeah
i don't know if you want to hear if you
don't know the context of somebody next
to you in the urinal
and he goes oh shooter and he has no
idea what you're talking about as he
stares over
into your urinal
just saying chris i that might be a
little a little
awkward there awkward that's the key
word there dan
oh my god uh sandman are you starting to
play golf again because people want to
know
can you play golf and i said well you
can play i don't know if you're any good
but you're are you trying now
so about i i and chris i want to go out
with you man we were talking about this
so i was
i was like thanksgiving
we we i i didn't golf for like 15 years
since my kid
kids were born i stopped doing it and
then i started up
like around thanksgiving and i've been
playing every day
since just trying to sneak it in and um
sounds like somebody's getting ready for
a happy gilmore two
i do the i i i do the normal swing when
i'm playing but um
i still i can't like yesterday i played
nine
i was like oh i'm about to score pretty
well and then i blew up and shot an
eight on one hole i never
i can't i can't get the score i can't i
can't have a score great how about you
chris you've been playing
uh short game is is good for me i don't
i don't drive it like you do of course
but
just just do you know how many this is
what's great about this movie and
all the many years for me to be get the
entre into the
pro the pga guys i meet rory
mcilroy i mean i meet all these great
players jt
you know dj all these guys and they all
try that
shot they all do it it's they
they think it's the funniest thing in
the world and it's also illegal
not illegal but a legal shot anything
you do behind the ball apparently
is legal and just so these guys are
crushing and i'm going god they're good
athletes
but you know that's what it takes it's a
good athlete to hit that shot but do i
play a lot of golf
it's like with you i have children i
have responsibilities i don't get out
enough i live up in an
area where my golf club is really cold
right now i can't go out there it's like
you know 30 degrees so uh but i go and
play a lot of charity events
i get invited to a lot of events and if
it's raising money for cancer or
whatever it is i'm happy to do it and we
have a lot of fun it's a scramble it's a
different kind of a thing but that's how
i get out and i love it
25 years ago man pretty crazy
still holds up i loved it and i loved
getting to know chris
and and and i and and chris just so you
know when you said yes to the movie
it made us so happy and and you were
known as a great actor
and we kept thinking because you know it
is a great actor it's going to just make
people say okay we can hang with great
actors man
it was a big deal well and and chris was
in
uh quiz show and with with ray fine so
who's a better actor chris adam sandler
or ray finds don't
put me on that spot why don't you you
put you put adam sandler in a comedy he
wins you put adam
you put adam sandler in a drama he wins
because
how great was punch drunk love how great
was
how great was the uncut gems i mean i
don't know
rape finds is great don't get me wrong
but he's very very very english
he couldn't have played happy gilmore
chris not a
chance sam man that's got to feel good i
mean you're not going to win an academy
award probably but that's got to feel
pretty good
that felt good i like what whatever
fellow uh from shooter mcgavin i feel
good hey he won a spirit award for that
which is awesome where is your spirit
award
where do i keep it yeah
it just it's it's it's next is
it's next to a punt passing kick
[Laughter]
hey guys uh thanks for joining us we
appreciate it
and uh chris you're a good sport thanks
for joining us and hopefully we have
happy gilmore two the senior tour
with uh you guys uh that would be great
but but thanks again we appreciate you
guys joining us
thank you dan i say one thing before we
go daddy you're sorry
oh everybody who uh invited me and chris
out like in the pga stuff and
and all those and all the players who
were nice to us and tweeting nice stuff
the only only reason i i can't jump
right into playing those tournaments is
i have this stupid schedule i can't make
it those times but sometime
me and chris i would love for us to go
and and play with those guys and and uh
raise money for something that would be
the greatest thank you guys
and prayers out to tigers tiger woods
right now it's got to be tragic i know i
didn't uh we didn't want to bring that
up but uh
let's hope it doesn't it's not a career
ending thing and he's uh he's up on his
feet pretty soon well he's alive that's
why he said people should celebrate the
fact that he's alive uh
chris uh thanks for joining us the uh
the great actor christopher mcdonald and
of course the uh great actor adam
sandler uh thank you guys
love you guys okay you guys thank you
thank you bud